hello and welcome to this video playing
with with greater with greater this is
certainly touch those a dutch flag but
don't ask me what it means I do
understand some Dutch but absolutely not
everything so when do we get get this
all right okay who created some is a
rare move but not a bad move i think
something that i found while researching
my book everybody plays knight c6 but
there is no particular reason not to
play with Iain okay maybe here if I said
some wacky double attack might be em
some becky double attack I want to cook
in d5 but maybe this is not possible him
Bishop Hanks and rook hangs this is what
bothers me and so I don't see a
refutation and he is not really trying
for one it seems okay
yeah white can always play Knight to f4
or Knight to c3 and then push t5 and you
can play all kinds of other things of
course this is one of the typical moves
yeah probably is our foot Bishop b4 and
yeah and then t5ho IRA likely anyway
have to play the same and now where'd
you go oh maybe just back right it's
annoying though really is maybe this is
a square
yeah so now 285 also go here and this is
running right into Bishop e3 em this is
just completely idiotic wonder what a
stupid move of course he plays but
should be three and not d5 sometimes you
really have to wonder what kind of ideas
you have at chess ah what a how long
yeah I'm just gifting him that move
completely completely pointless Wow I
know that looks pretty awful but we
don't move the Queen again I mean just
yeah I am that's what you get for being
creative probably I should have just
played my tried and tested mainline
brownie now okay so let's see what he's
doing even just trading Queens as good
of course but he's got probably stronger
moves yeah and the i don't know i'm also
down on time so try to play quickly and
bishops e2 and my queen is trapped or
no I can actually take be true which
took me took me ages to realize and so
maybe then it's set not so bad maybe I
can take the this now I can snatch that
pawn which is immensely cheeky I think
I'll take him
this is this is not so bad unless I'm
overlooking stuff which is very possible
that currently and I don't know what
he's doing here yeah again so these six
is the move that annoys me so let's stop
it now I've got the payoff Bishop some
if he's not killing me quickly then this
is not such a bad position at all that
green and I knew I was really outlandish
when I play okay
my queen is somewhat misplaced so no
it's not misplace i mean it it is an
annoying peaceful white also but i have
to be wary of traps 94 or something but
it isn't really doing that much and i
have to control you for you anyway but
it's it's really good now unless there's
some direct technical thing that I don't
see I really don't 594 something I can
just go here think yeah okay this is a
fantastic ending plus the time
could have taken the pawn already
resigned yeah so well there was a
absolutely terrible opening play I think
this is this is ok but here I should
take with the upon which is admittedly
very boring but also very equal and this
is probably asking a bit too much on the
position you know I mean what if this is
just ridiculous allowing this Yemen and
here why this just better he must be
must be better here the engine just
wants to take and play room to be one
yeah I mean of course why it's better I
have no development yeah mymy bit by
pieces are back here this is actually
not that great for wide
chess is a strange game really something
that i played this like an idiot and
just one one bad move by Wyatt and and
it's okay again and I'm really
completely okay and after if I'm a
better because he has to go back the
engine i actually just want to snatch be
two words I mean I'm happy with this
position mm-hmm okay computers to go f5
and thinks this is not so great because
of the 53 set not preparing might be 50
/ do this are then 19 four winds I are
again so it has its residents 94 and if
I do this it's not be 50 kb should be
three as strong then what do you have to
do it this one hmm wow I was a strong
yeah here black is basically winning
with the bishops and all the week pawns
the plus in this case the time but turn
okay also the position now is winning it
was very lucky after pretty pretty awful
opening okay who thanks for watching